ÇEs ist eigentlich der verstšrendste Clip,
den wir je gemacht haben
und das alles fŸr euch.È
ÇClarice Lispector.È
ÇWie? Was ist das denn fŸr eine
neue Aussprache?È
ÇDas ist ein Klassiker
der Weltliteratur aus SŸdamerika.
Ihre Geschichten sind
sehr speziell.
Also wenn man sie sieht,
eine Frau, die ausschaut
wie eine Sphinx,
und genauso rŠtselhaft
sind auch ihre Geschichten.È
ÇWas auch interessant ist, ist ja,
dass sie wahnsinnig berŸhmt ist.È
ÇIn SŸdamerika.È
ÇUnd in Europa ziemlich unbekannt.
Es ist nicht der erste Versuch,
sie bekannt zu machen
mit †bersetzungen.
Und irgendwie hat das nie so richtig funktioniert.È
ÇUnd weisst du, woran das liegt?È
ÇNein, sag mal.È
ÇDie Geschichten von ihr
sind alle rŠtselhaft.
Sie haben oft was Surreales.
Und dann gibt es aber,
jedenfalls in diesem Band,
sexuelle Begehrens-Geschichten.È
ÇNicola stellt das Buch jetzt total
unter verzerrten...È
ÇIch rede noch!È
ÇJa, ich muss sofort intervenieren,
weil du schaffst hier Kaufanreize,
die du gar nicht...È
ÇNatŸrlich!È
ÇAlso dieses Buch hat
ganz viele Geschichten,
die Hausfrauen-Schicksale
behandeln.
Und ich meine das
nicht despektierlich.
Sondern es geht da um
den Typus einer gutsituierten
Frau, die zu Hause sitzt,
und keine richtige
SinnbestŠtigung in
ihrem Leben findet.È
ÇDiese typischen Geschichten
muss man mal definieren.È
ÇAlso die typische Geschichte
fŸr mich, ist eine Geschichte,
in der eine gewisse
Verlorenheit herrscht,
wo die Hauptfigur, die fast immer
eine weibliche Figur ist,
zerrieben wird zwischen
zwei grossen Punkten,
den Erwartungen der anderen
und der eigenen Freiheit.
Die †berforderung des Menschen
durch die Freiheit,
ist zum Beispiel ein
prototypischer Lispector Inhalt.È
ÇErgŠnzt Ÿber diese Elemente,
die etwas Traumhaftes an sich haben.
Wo man nicht genau weiss,
bewegen sich die Geschichten
in der reinen RealitŠt,
oder im Kopf der Figur,
die gerade beschrieben wird.È
ÇWenn du mich fragst...È
ÇDieses doppelbšdige...È
ÇMich fragt sie nicht.È
ÇNein, ich frage dich nicht.
Weil du redest
ja auch ungefragt.È
ÇSie hat mich noch nie was gefragt.
Und ausserdem sehen
meine Haare gut aus.È
ÇDas Innenleben der Figuren,
das macht Clarice Lispector
in meinen Augen aus.È
ÇVielleicht bin ich auch eher
so ein bodenstŠndiges, schlichtes GemŸt,
aber ich habe die Geschichten
von den Hausfrauen lieber.
Das finde ich alles viel interessanter
als diese ekstatisch-mystischen Sachen,
die mir schwerer zugŠnglich sind.È
ÇIch habe das deswegen so betont,
weil du mich gefragt hast,
warum Clarice Lispector hier
noch nicht so bekannt ist,
wie es schšn wŠre.
Du hast mich nicht zu Ende reden lassen.È
ÇNein, weil es hat so lange gedauert
und es wurde wieder
Nacht und wieder Tag.
Es gibt immer so
ein Dreh in den Figuren.È
ÇDas wŠre jetzt noch das dritte Element,
die Ÿberraschenden Wendungen.È
ÇGenau. Aber ich mšchte nochmal
darauf zurŸckkommen, dass du gesagt hast,
das, was sie vielleicht etwas
unattraktiver machen wŸrde,
auch fŸr den Erfolg beim Publikum,
ist dieses Verstšrende.È
ÇIch habe nicht gesagt, dass das Verstšrende
die Leser verstšrt, sondern...È
ÇDu verstšrst mich gerade nachhaltig.È
Ç...dass die Kombination
aus dem Mystischen
mit den Ÿberraschenden Wendungen,
mit den sehr expliziten Szenen
zum sexuellen Begehren...È
ÇDie gibt's gar nicht.È
Ç...die Lesenden unter UmstŠnden
verstšren kšnnte.È
ÇDieser ganze Clip ist jetzt
schon hochgradig verstšrend.È
ÇWir haben diesen Clip
ja auch gemacht,
weil ihr es wolltet.È
ǆberlegt euch gut, was ihr als
nŠchstes wollt,
denn wir machen es.È